hello everyone this game I have prepared
for you is the real masterpiece it was
played in 1935 in Ukraine and it's
played between F and kortchmar and
Abramovich polyak and well I couldn't
really find any information on mr.
[ __ ] and the very little information
on mr. mr. mr. F in kortchmar other than
he was a Soviet chess player and that he
was a coach but I did find an entry in
the Russian Wikipedia I will put it in
the description below so you can check
it out if you want to learn some more
about him but it's really his greatest
achievement in chess is playing this
game that holds the title the Ukrainian
immortal so let's see this game mr. F in
horse Mar is white and mr. polyak is
black we have E 4 E 592 f3 Knight to c6
and Bishop to b5 the reuleaux PES and
here we have d6 the old Steinitz defense
b4 Bishop to d7 Knight to c3 Knight to
f6 white castles and now Knight captures
on d4 and this isn't considered the best
move because while White will get a very
nice central square for his queen Bishop
captures on d7 with Czech clean capture
77 Knight capture Sun before he captures
on d4 and Queen captures and v4 and this
queen is well it's a beautiful square
for the Queen I will have Bishop d7
rook to d1 preparing d5 and black
castles and white indeed does push a e5
of course the black can captured is
because he loses a piece as you can see
row capture 77 white is up a piece so
after he 5 uh mr. Pollard goes night to
e8 and here we have Bishop to f4
if black captures the pawn Queen
captures pawn and well this rockin d1 is
very nicely eyeing that Queen 97 and the
black plays a5 he wants some expansion
on the Queen side we have work to do
and well I always enjoy a good rook lift
whenever I see a rook lift I know that
that this will be a great game we have
worked to a6 and now rook to e1 Queen to
f5 and our Knight study
attacking that Bishop on e7 and while
threatening a knife captors on e7
forking the king and the Queen
so Bishop to d8 and this Bishop is now
nicely controlling this knight on d5 we
have it captures an b6
Knight captures and e6 and now rook to
g3 okay mr. ethem is threatening mate
and g7 so this has to be defended that
we have f6 and now Bishop to h6
now threatening rook captures on g7
would check black defense this rook to
f7 and we have Knight to be four and
well this is a pretty amazing move I
mean what's the idea here the idea is
that black can't really capture the
knight so white is actually winning a
rope this rock on a6 but mr. polio did I
wasn't really convinced that the knight
was immune from capture so he captured
it a capture some before and well this
is the first brilliant move of the game
and in this position mr. mr. FM
kortchmar plays Queen captures on d6 and
well this is an this is an amazing move
as the the King cannot be captured if
you capture the Queen for example
recapture send e6 it doesn't matter if
you capture with the record upon you got
a rook to e8 check and after rook to f8
you get rook captures and g7 would check
only move King to h8 and rook captures
on a fate with checkmate
so after this Queen to d6 the Queen
cannot be captured so black has to play
something else
it arises the Queen to d7 now defending
and here comes the second brilliant move
of the game and I believe this move is
even more brilliant than the previous
one and he plays Queen to d5 now again
offering his queen of course the Queen
cannot be captured if you capture the
Queen you lose to the same idea of rook
e8
but now the screen is actually pinning
this rook on f7 so now rook captures and
g7 is again a threat so black place
we're looking to f8 now I'm pinning from
this idea and well this is the third
brilliant move of the game in this
position
mr. court smart plays rook captures and
g7 totally disregarding that well the
rook isn't pinned anymore so what do you
play here if you captured the
rook well then Queen captures and d7 is
completely winning as now the rook is
pinned since the king is now on f8 so
after this rook captures and g7 idea
black decided to capture the Queen we
have Queen captures on d5 but now now
white can play for example rook to g5
with the discover check from the bishop
and then capture the Queen and he will
be upon up this will be okay for him but
instead he finds the third brilliant
move of the game and that's rook to g8
with with a double check and only move
for the black king is to capture the
rook and well even though he really
tried to get away from g8 and he played
that came to f8 move you know to get
away I didn't do it much good only movie
screen captures and g8 we have rook to
e8 with Czech rock to f8 defending only
move and now rook captures and f8 with
checkmate so yeah definitely brilliant
game definitely deserving of the name
the Ukrainian immortal and I believe it
equally stands with all other immortal
games throughout chess history so yeah I
would like to thank Alexandra room and
Brendan C for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
and just for fun I will put a link in
the description below where mr. effin
kortchmar faces the rashidun age midi
note it's also quite a game be sure to
check it out so yeah as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I'll see
you soon